my wife sharon would put it
all all government overreach all
socialism and all other forms of
government overreach always starts out
under the auspices of an emergency and i
think that's
the awful truth to which the american
people have awakened over the last two
years they've realized oh my gosh if
they can call something in emergency
they can do anything they want and when
government can do anything it wants and
the people feel fear the government
rather than
the other way around
horrible things happen so yeah i think
that has created
a number of accidental conservatives and
libertarians in this country as they've
seen that horrible abuses of government
as it goes unquestioned uh all under the
auspices of uh well this is necessary
because of an emergency
so since you are a guy that cares about
the actual rules and the way that we're
supposed to be governed i mean in effect
it seems like we're at war right now i
mean we haven't declared war i know the
president's supposed to declare war and
has to get authorized and everything
else but i mean when you're pouring tons
of money into something when you're
giving people weapons etc etc you in
essence are at war i mean at what point
do we start looking at that and and
having congress or the senate go boy uh
are we at war and how much money do you
have to pour into something before you
officially call it war and if you keep
giving a guy weapons maybe it is war or
again is that just one of those things
that it's just kind of it is what it is
and the the beat goes on yeah i think
it's it's absolutely essential that
before we take
any more steps in the direction of
warfare
um that we take into account our role as
a congress in declaring war
over many decades congress has gradually
relinquished its
declaration of war powers
as
presidents of both political parties
have asserted really broad powers uh
attached to their inherent authority
under article two as commander in chief
of the armed forces
this is problematic because it was one
of the distinguishing characteristics
of the constitution one of the things
that made it very different than the
english model the system that we had
just broken away from
allowed the chief executive the king
to take us to war and then it was up to
parliament to figure out how to pay for
it
under our system federalist 69 makes
this very clear when alexander alexander
hamilton explains that it was with good
reason we put the power to declare war
in the first instance in the hands of
congress because that's the branch most
accountable to the people at the most
regular intervals so i think if we're
going to take
any additional steps in this area we
really ought to have a conversation
about whether in what way to what extent
we want to be involved in a conflict
with russia
keep in mind ukraine spends less than
five billion dollars a year in defense
russia spends about 65 billion dollars a
year in defense if you add up the
previous ukraine bill 14 billion to this
ukraine bill uh 40 billion
you're talking about
more than 10 times what ukraine spends
on defense
in an entire year
uh is what
we have devoted in the name of ukraine
defense and we're knocking on the door
of what russia spends on defense
worldwide in an entire year
do you think we're in a bizarre
situation as the last superpower that
we're still expected to do everything
but maybe we kind of just can't in a
certain respect i i personally believe
that i believe in american
exceptionalism i believe the world is
better when we're leading i believe in
peace through strength all of those
things but that maybe right now
especially with the leadership that we
have that we just can't do that much
good at the moment in in these big
international things well yeah look i
think this is where we get dangerously
off course i think it is dangerous for
any country
last standing superpower or not to step
into the mindset that says
if there is injustice in the world we
can be counted on as the presumptive
uh
police force
no nation can do that no nation can
withstand that
certainly we can't our constitutional
system should never allow that to happen
what really needs to happen is that
anytime we get involved militarily
we really ought to have congress
declaring war before we take any action
in that direction and
always the inquiry should be on
not on whether bad people are doing bad
things in another part of the world
but on how that affects american
national security the safety security
the liberty of the american people at
home
if we can't connect it to that
we shouldn't be doing it
because there is no end to the threats
that we will face the battles we will
have to fight with no real corresponding
ability
uh
to do all of those things if our only
test is to go out there and find bad
people doing bad things we'll be very
busy so busy indeed that we will leave
the american people vulnerable in their
own homeland
so speaking of safety and liberty at
home uh you know two years or two and a
half years post covid um are you
are you hopeful that more people have
woken up to some of the state's right
stuff some of the stuff related to the
courts and mandates and all of the
overreach that we saw i mean my sense is
that a lot of people really have woken
up i i don't know if they got scared
again if they would just drop all of
their newfound ideas very quickly in the
name of security but i'm kind of hopeful
at the moment yeah
as my my wife sharon would put it um
all all government overreach all
socialism and all other forms of
government overreach it always starts
out
under the auspices of an emergency and i
think that's
the awful truth to which the american
people have awakened over the last two
years they've realized oh my gosh if
they can call something an emergency
they can do anything they want and when
government can do anything it wants and
the people feel fear the government
rather than uh the other way around uh
horrible things happen so yeah i think
that has created a number of accidental
conservatives and libertarians in this
country as they've seen that horrible
abuses of government as it goes
unquestioned uh all under the auspices
of uh well this is necessary because of
an emergency
what do we do about organizations like
the cdc and the fda i mean they're
they're not legislative bodies but in
essence it seems like they legislate and
then they it seems like well you just
turn on any corporate news and they're
all sponsored by pfizer sponsored by
moderna as they're uh doing stories on
pfizer on moderna what do we do about
that mess yeah
it's a it's a great point and by the way
i i talk about this a fair amount in
saving nine that's why i like to say
saving nine is not just about the
supreme court it's not just about court
packing it explains all of the maladies
that that
flow inevitably from court packing and
flowed
from fdr's court packing threat back in
the 1930s as a result of that we've got
too much power that's been moved from
the people to washington than within
washington too much power that has been
voluntarily relinquished by the people's
elected lawmakers and handed out to
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats
people at the cdc and the fda or the two
that you mentioned you've noticed of
late it's been getting worse and worse
as the centers for disease control
is uh a whole lot more about the control
than the disease
and the fda rather than just looking out
for
protecting the american people from
unsafe products
is all about controlling them
controlling even the information to
which they may gain access
this is the predictable foreseeable and
i believe avoidable result of congress
outsourcing the task of legislation we
have for decades had a congress that's
in in effect saying we hereby declare
that we shall have good law in area x
and we hereby delegate to
commission or department y the power to
make
good law in that area and then they get
to make the law and enforce it that's a
recipe for tyranny
so going on the assumption that there
will be a covid ii or another version of
something this or as your wife would say
something else that will scare us in the
future
what actual authority does the cdc have
i think that was one of the things that
really confused people that every day
someone from the cdc wilhenski or one of
these people would get up there they
would say something and then people
automatically felt oh that's what they
said we have to do it but that's not
exactly how this thing works right it's
not exactly how it works but there
there's enough legislation on the books
that gives these government agencies
including the cdc
at least a colorable claim
to
the authority to dictate how much of our
economy runs
that
they can
get by the initial smell test
and see not everything gets litigated
there's another point i make in saving
nine not every dispute not every
question about constitutionality
goes to the supreme court most cases
don't even get litigated the a very
small percentage of those that get
litigated make their way all the way to
the supreme court and it can take months
or sometimes years to get to the bottom
of some of these problems in the
meantime a lot of the these disputes
have become moot and the courts then
start to lack jurisdiction over them
that's why we need
genuine deep reform where we withdraw
the authority the delegated authority to
make new law it's one of the reasons why
i believe so strongly and the need to
pass things like the reins act look if i
were in charge of of
and and i had just one uh
legislative
measure that i could pick and guarantee
passage of it would be the reigns act
their acronym is reins stands for
regulations from the executive in need
of scrutiny to make a long story short
it says that we're not going to allow
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats to
make our laws anymore that will be done
only by congress and when an executive
branch agency uses delegate authority to
create what is in effect a new law that
will not be self-executing after the
passage of the reigns act it will
require an affirmative vote by congress
to pass it into law you see people can
fire their elected lawmakers
periodically you can't fire a government
bureaucrat that's why we need the reins
act if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell